hello everyone this video is about the
greatest technical error in chess
history he was known by many names
the magician from Riga the pirate of
Latvia fortunes favorite the hypnotist
and so on this is the moment you've all
been waiting for
top 10 facts about Mikhail nikolaevitch
towel number 1 Mikal towel was born on
9th of november 1936 he was a soviet
latvian chess grandmaster in the 8th
world chess champion from 1960 to 1961
widely regarded as a creative genius and
the best detecting player of all time
tall played in a daring combinatorial
style his play was well known above all
from improvisation and unpredictability
every game he once said was as
inimitable and invaluable as a poem the
McHale town memorial has been held in
Moscow annually since 2006 to honor
Palace memory number 2 tall was born in
Riga Latvia into a Jewish family
according to his friend Gennady sosenko
his true father was a family friend
identified only as uncle Robert from the
very beginning of his life he suffered
from ill health I learned to read at the
age of three and was allowed to start
university studies while only 15 at the
age of 8 I learned to play chess while
watching his father a doctor and the
medical researcher number three shortly
thereafter he joined the Riga palace for
young pioneers chess club his play was
not exceptional at first but he worked
hard to improve Alexander Koblenz began
tutoring tall in 1949 after which tiles
game rapidly improved and by 1951 he had
qualified for the Latvian championship
in the 1952 Latvian Championship tile
finished ahead of his trainer tall won
his first life in title in 1953 and was
awarded the title of candidate master he
became a Soviet master in 1954 by
defeating Vladimir sigan in a qualifying
match that same year he also scored his
first win over a grandmaster when Yuri
overbook lost on time in a wrong
position the opening tell used wood
white for this game was the Belgrade
gambit number four Talman a very strong
tournament at Zurich in 1959 following
the inter zonal the top players carried
out to the candidates tournament
Yugoslavia 1959 tall showed superior
form but winning with 20 out of 28
points I had a fall Karras with 18 and a
half followed by Tigran Petrosian vasily
smyslov
the 16 year old bobby fischer svetozar
gligar rich friedrich olaf stone and pal
Benko thousand victories was a
to his dominance over the lower half of
the field while scoring only one win and
three losses versus Karras he won all
four individual games against Fisher and
took three and a half points out of four
from each league rich full of stones and
Benko number five in 1960 at the age of
23
tall defeated the relatively strategic
Mikhail Botvinnik in a world
championship match held in Moscow by 12
and a half to eight and a half points
six wins two losses and 13 draws making
him the youngest ever world champion a
record later broken by Garry Kasparov
who earned the title at 22
number six between ik who had never
faced tall before the title match won
the return match against Al in 1961 also
held in Moscow by 13 to 8 10 wins the
five with six draws in the period
between the matches both minica
thoroughly analyzed tall style and
turned most of the return matches games
into slow Wars of maneuver or end games
rather than the complicated tactical
melees which were tossed happy hunting
ground
toss chronic kidney problems contributed
to his defeat and his doctors in riga
advised the t-shirt postpone the match
for health reasons yuri arabic claimed
that Botvinnik would agree to a
postponement only if tal was certified
unfit by Moscow doctors his short reign
atop the chess world made him one of the
so-called two winter Kings who
interrupted both winix long reign from
1948 to 1963 the other was miss love
world champion from 1957 to 1958 his
highest a low rating was twenty seven
hundred and five achieved in 1980
his highest historical chess metric
rating was twenty seven hundred and
ninety nine number seven it was the 12th
round low to 2040 USSR championship in
1957 Michael Tala turned his game with
boleslav ski in a very difficult
position straight after play
tall went off to a date with a girl
while the other players were enjoying
their sleep
tal spent the time walking around the
streets of Moscow next to the Belarus
key railway station they cross the road
in the wrong place and the policeman
arrested them and brought to the police
station the young lieutenant who was on
duty turned to look at them with
dissatisfaction and returned to the task
he had had to break off he was sitting
with a chess board in front of him Pal
glanced at the board and couldn't
suppress a smile the police officer was
analyzing towson game with boleslav ski
obviously the adjourned game has been
dictated in the unique sport bulletin on
the radio
l was unable to restrain himself and
is on a move made on the board instead
of replying to lieutenant push the board
away from him and in a bored voice asked
named Todd what another one you'll laugh
I know said Misha but I'm not another
one I'm the very man himself a minute
later they were analyzing the position
together Colin went home only at 7:00
a.m.
despite the health of the police the
game was still lost in resumption number
eight here is an anecdote I read in a
book called life in games of Michael Tao
Tao was playing against Grandmaster
Masuka they reached a very complicated
position and Thal was considering a
knight sacrifice I know what you're
thinking what else would all be
considering but to his horror he
couldn't fight any good continuations
suddenly he started to think about a
hippopotamus drowning in a swamp he
tried to figure out how to save the poor
hippo after 40 minutes of thinking about
the problem towel realized he couldn't
save the poor hippo and that something
simply can be calculated he realized
that the night sacrifice was purely
intuitive and it promised an interesting
game the following day the newspapers
wrote how tall after thinking for 40
minutes about the position managed to
calculate all the variations and win the
game with a great night sacrifice little
did they know that four people had to
drown for tall to win the game number
nine
Michael Tom married three times in 1959
he marries 19 year old Russian actor
Sally Landau this marriage lasted for 11
years and ended in divorce in 1970 his
second marriage too did not last long he
later married Angeline of the two Cove
who worked in the Riga shock matty
magazine he had been a sickly child
though he had fairly good health during
his youth he suffered from kidney
problems that intensified over time he
underwent several surgeries over the
years and even was the kidney Fury's
illness an eccentric man with a bohemian
lifestyle he became addicted to smoking
and drinking which further affected his
self McHale Kyle died on 28th of June
1992 of a hemorrhage in the esophagus
he was just 55 and number 10 to
understand Michael talib is more here is
what garry kasparov said about him I
worked a bit with tall around 1980 he
visited Bach
we played a couple of training games and
the chess context wasn't lost until
Todd's very last days there was a blitz
tournament in Moscow one month before
towels death
he looked horrible but Stahl was still
tall in this blitz tournament I lost my
only game to him I retaliated in the
second round but the fact was that
the very end he still had his vision of
the games he was the only one I knew who
didn't have to calculate the lines he
saw them we calculate he does this I do
that and tall through all the thick
layers of the variants so that around
the eighth move it will be so and so
some people can see the mathematical
formula they can imagine the whole
picture instantly an ordinary man has to
calculate to think this through but they
just see it all
it occurs in great musicians great
scientists thought was absolutely unique
his playing style was of course
unrepeatable i calculated the variance
quickly enough but these tall insights
were unique he was a man in whose
presence others sense their mediocrity
as usual I have a question for you if
tom was to play some today's top grand
masters who have computer lines
memorized - who knows what move how do
you think he would do would he be able
to dictate the tone of the battle as he
did in his era or his style style of
play simply not possible in modern chess
this video was a bit longer than the
rest but that is my favorite and I
wanted to pay the great measure this
small tribute for new players just
starting to learn about chess and it's
great champion studying the life and
games of Michael Todd is a must if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up and a comment and if you're
interested when my new video will be
released subscribe to my channel and hit
the little bell button after and as the
magician from riga would say there are
two types of sacrifices correct ones and
mine for the end of this video enjoyed
this rare footage of tal's first
encounter with Bobby Fischer see you
next week
Bobby t-shirt and a sledge yet for it's
a sabbatical he wrote directed and SSG
do gig ordinary houses Lindsay and I
just a gzip or Forza Juve any subset is
measurable fischeri
in school Italia
like Adam Fisher Tepito yes absolute
certain algebraic oh is that panties and
Nagar Haveli Catherine Abbate
Villa Takako tally glad a certain very
concerning watching official likely it
blasts Tchaikovsky Guinea a questionable
janila Napo Clara's artist Jacques
[Music]
[Music]
you